the year was 1861. arthur duplice one of
the world's most renowned explorers and
adventurers hacked through the thick
vines of the amazon rainforest with a
well-worn machete he grunted and
strained his clothes heavy and skin
slick with sweat he took a deep swig
from his canteen and paused briefly to
breathe this was the second week of his
solo expedition into the lung of the
world and the process had been grueling
he'd fought off piranhas electric eels
and invasive kandaru fish while wading
and kayaking down the amazon river he'd
contended with tribesmen and poachers
and narrowly dodged his fair share of
poisonous beasties that could take down
prey three times their size no sane man
would brave this horror for its own sake
but arthur has as good a reason as any
he was searching for his younger brother
joseph duplicise who had disappeared a
month earlier during a trek through the
amazon joseph had always admired his
brother's wild adventures and sought to
imitate him it was for that very reason
that arthur had felt responsible for his
brother's current predicament and made
it his mission to rescue him the amazon
is an ancient and cruel mistress the
arrogant and foolish have hoped to
conquer or tame her for centuries but
countless men had disappeared in the
pulsing heart of this green behemoth
arthur may have been a world-class
explorer in a different league to many
of the others whose lives this green
inferno has handedly taken but there
were creatures lurking deep in the
amazon that went beyond even arthur's
knowledge the kind of beasts that would
make the darkest and most twisted
nightmares look comparatively inviting
beasts like
scp-2031 if joseph was able to send
arthur one more message before it all
came to a horrible end we could only
imagine it'd be something like don't
come for me it's already too late but
there's still time to save yourself
brother stay away for god's sake stay
away
you have no idea what you're dealing
with here
forget about me
go while there's still time sadly for
arthur duplessis that time was about to
run out he ventured further into the
depths of the amazon where even light
was scarce under the thick canopy above
a mighty green anaconda slithered
through a nearby tributary tongue
flailing in search of prey an amazonian
giant centipede a centipede so large and
vicious it preys on snakes and bats
skittered up a nearby tree on 46
needle-like legs a big meaty tarantula
definitely navigated the branches above
while tree frogs with poison potent
enough to put an entire army six feet
under hopped through the rich
undergrowth humans held no power here
arthur fell to his knees and began to
weep his foolish ambitions had gotten
his dear brother killed in this awful
place shot to death by poachers
strangled by anacondas or eaten alive by
vicious bull sharks in the amazon river
there were so many horrible ways that
joseph could had died and in the absence
of ever finding a body all of them would
simultaneously be true the duplessis
family would never know peace there
would be a void and emptiness in all of
their hearts forever but just when
arthur was about to give up hope
something miraculous happened he saw a
human figure stumbling around faintly in
the distance arthur drew his trusty
pistol assuming it could be a poacher or
a hostile tribesman but something was
different the figure had its back to
arthur but he recognized its shirt a
distinctive shade of light blue just
like the shirt that arthur had bought
for joseph on his previous birthday
could it be was it really him arthur
holstered his weapon and jumped to his
feet he couldn't let this figure get
away even if there was only the tiniest
chance it could actually be his brother
and not some kind of force mirage arthur
ran towards the figure with the last of
his energy reserves panting and wheezing
he called his brother's name again and
again but the figure didn't respond it
just stumbled along as though drunk but
the closer arthur got the more certain
he was that this was indeed his brother
the height the hair the clothes the
build it was joseph duplicise but why
wasn't he responding why wouldn't he
turn around as arthur finally reached
the figure he ground to a halt the most
profound sense of dread fell over him
like a sudden monsoon something
unnatural something truly terrible was
about to happen but he didn't know what
and moreover it was too late to stop now
feeling anxiety prickling up his legs
and back arthur reached forward to grab
his brother by the shoulder the word
joseph trembling on his lips when
arthur's hand touched joseph's shoulder
he felt a fear greater than anything
he'd experienced before something was
moving beneath the skin of joseph's
shoulder something writhing and alive a
million tiny creatures all working
together in his brother's flesh before
he could even draw his hand away his
brother turned or rather the creatures
that were wearing his brother's body
turned around arthur couldn't help but
scream at the horrible sight before him
his brother's face looked loose and
rotten aging skin hanging off a rotting
skull his jaw hung loose no tongue
inside no eyes either just millions of
ants swarming in and out of joseph
duplessis vacant dead face the ants were
huge and spiny with long curved
mandibles ektian bruschelli a
particularly hearty species of new world
army ant arthur stepped back babbling in
terror at what had become of his brother
the joseph sued stepped forward towards
him and almost instinctively arthur
pushed him with both hands feeling the
nightmarish activity swarming beneath
the loose cover of joseph's bony chest
the joseph suits tumbled backward
tripping over a rock and burst there
were no organs left inside his brother
now they'd been eaten long ago it was
just a thin tarpon of gray skin over dry
bones and of course millions upon
millions of ants now making a bee line
for arthur with the frightening military
precision any naturalists could expect
from ekitan burchelli but while army
ants could be a formidable and
frightening foe in their own right
nobody had seen any ants like this
before while nobody who'd lived to tell
the tale at least arthur turned to flee
but sadly it was already too late for
him what he thought were mere prickles
of anxiety were actually an invasion
force of ekton burchelli soldiers which
had positioned themselves over key
nerves and ligaments on his skin and
spine as arthur tried to run away the
ants began to bite into him cutting
through skin rending bone and munching
into the chewing neurons underneath
arthur felt intense flashes of pain all
over his body before collapsing to the
ground paralyzed that's when the true
horrors began if there was one
consolation for arthur in this last
terrible hours of his life he would at
least know firsthand exactly how his
brother died he couldn't move but he
could feel everything the creatures
chewed through the flesh of his
extremities cutting holes in his skin
and creating openings for swarms of
their insect brethren to enter through
arthur felt like he was on fire as the
swarm entered his body but was unable to
do anything about it death by these
creatures is a slow and torturous
experience unlike their non-anomalous
counterparts the swarms don't
immediately start devouring all
available soft tissue
scp-2031 wants to keep their prey alive
while they renovate their new home
arthur finally died two days later from
dehydration it was at this point that
the creatures finally began eating his
organs and eventually distributing their
colony throughout his body the ants even
produce an enzyme that slows the
decaying process for their deceased
hosts that's why joseph duplicise didn't
look a whole lot worse by the time
arthur found him even though he'd
already suffered a month of post-mortem
infestation not long after arthur's
death the arthur suit got up and walked
away the world would never know how or
why arthur duplicise and his brother
disappeared in the dark heart of the
amazon jungle but perhaps for the sake
of all those who loved them ignorance is
actually kinder than the truth it would
be almost a century before the
foundation finally discovered these
creatures on a nearby farm designated
them
scp-2031 and began containment and
testing they soon became aware of what
arthur joseph and many others had
learned the hard way while they may be
relatively ineffectual individually
together these insects were a real force
to be reckoned with very few
non-anomalous animals had any chance of
escaping them once they'd set their
sights on a target and began assuming
their attack positions in one observed
instance
scp-2031 soldiers were able to take down
a 1 000 kilogram angus bull in five
minutes most of which was just spent
getting their soldiers into their proper
positions over the spine and leg
ligaments the foundation just got
extremely lucky that these vicious
insect predators happened to be isolated
to some pretty specific areas in south
america thanks to the climate
requirements of their habitats in fact
pretty much all of the specimens the
foundation found were all in one place
the creatures had developed a
particularly frightening form of ant
farm known as scp-2031-a
an isolated containment zone on a
stretch of farmland where the ants could
find hosts in the form of life people
and animals keeping them relatively
isolated 27 separate
scp-2031 colonies were first found on
this farm inhabiting and operating 27
different corpses these include 15 cows
five different horses three domestic
pigs one dog and most fascinating of all
three human specimens an adult male an
adult female and a child of unspecified
gender what's even more fascinating than
the efficacy of these ants and attacking
all different kinds of prey is their
deafness and mimicking the behavior of
their hosts this isn't a reconstructive
maggot situation see our video on that
nightmare for further information the
ants attempt to make their hosts
actually act like the creatures they
once were the foundation were astonished
to see that the three human suits seemed
to actually go through the motions of
running the farm watering the livestock
dispensing feed moving other scp-2031
colonies from one pasture to another the
human child suit would even spend
extensive time playing with the dog suit
engaging in games such as fetch or mock
wrestling how the scp-2031 colonies are
able to do this is unknown working
theories include rigorous observation of
their targets before colonization and
the colony hive minds somehow picking up
residual thoughts or muscle memory from
their victims non-anomalous ants
introduced to the scp-2031 colonies also
begin exhibiting anomalous traits so the
effects may somehow be contagious one of
the most fascinating moments of all came
when the structural integrity of the dog
suit finally gave out leading to its
colony exiting the body and returning to
more nomadic behavior typical of army
ants in search of a new host the strange
part was that the human suits actually
seemed to grieve for the deceased dog
suit with the child suit becoming
somewhat distressed that their playmate
was suddenly gone the two human suits
even took the carcass of the dog suit
and buried it in another pasture it was
unlike anything the foundation had
observed with
scp-2031 before at what point did
mimicry become sincere behavior because
now scp-2031 was seriously blurring the
lines it is in the best interest of the
foundation to keep this little ant farm
going both to keep scp-2031 distracted
from venturing further and causing
trouble and to further study the
fascinating behaviors and dynamics
exhibited by scp-2031 colonies in
captivity one of the researchers has
already put in a request for a new
golden retriever now go check out
scp-2852
sadistic madman party crasher cousin
johnny and
scp-5049 the skin salesman demon dan's
discount homunculus depot for more scps
that'll give you utterly horrific fates